which
in time saves nine the government will
introduce
new restrictions in england carefully
judged to
achieve the maximum reduction in the r
number
with the minimum damage to lives and
livelihoods i want to stress that this
is by no means a return
to the full lockdown of march
we're not issuing a general instruction
to stay at home we will ensure
that schools colleges and universities
stay open because
nothing is more important than the
education health and well-being
of our young people we will ensure that
businesses can stay open in a coveted
compliant way however we must take
action to
suppress the disease first we are once
again asking office workers
who can work from home to do so in key
public services and in all
professions where homeworking is not
possible
such as construction or retail people
should continue
to attend their workplaces and like
government this house will be free to
take forward its business
in a covered secure way which you mr
speaker
have pioneered second
from thursday all pubs bars
and restaurants must operate a table
service only mr speaker except for
takeaways
together with all hospitality venues
they must close
at 10 p.m and to help the police enforce
this rule i'm afraid
that means alas closing and not just
calling for last orders because
simplicity is paramount the same will
apply to takeaways
though deliveries can continue
thereafter i'm sorry
that this will affect many businesses
just getting back on their feet but we
must act
to stop the virus from being transmitted
in bars
and restaurants third we will
extend the requirement to wear face
coverings to include
staff in retail all users of taxis
and private hire vehicles and staff and
customers
in indoor hospitality except when seated
at a table to eat
or drink fourth in retail leisure and
tourism and other sectors
our covered secure guidelines will
become legal
obligations businesses will be fined
and could be closed if they breach the
rules
fifth now is the time to tighten up the
rule of six
i'm afraid that from monday a maximum of
15 people
will be able to attend wedding
ceremonies and
receptions though up to 30 i can still
attend a funeral as now
we will also have to extend the rule of
six to all adult indoor team sports
finally we have to acknowledge that the
spread of the virus is now
affecting our ability to reopen business
conferences exhibitions
and large sporting events so
we will not be able to do this from the
first of october and i recognize the
implications for our sports clubs
which are the life and soul of our
communities
and my right honourable friends the
chancellor and cultural secretary are
working
urgently on what we can do now to
support them
mr speaker these rules these measures
will only work if people comply and that
there is nothing more
frustrating for the vast majority
who do comply the law abiding majority
than the site of a
few are brazenly defying the rules so
these rules will be enforced by tighter
penalties we've already introduced a
fine of up to ten thousand pounds
for those who fail to safe isolate and
such fines
will now be applied to businesses
breaking cobia rules
the penalty for failing to wear a mask
or breaking the rule of 6 will now
double to 200 pounds
for a first offense we will provide the
police and local authorities
with the extra funding they need a
greater police presence
on our streets and the option to draw
military support
where we're required to free up the
police
the measures i've announced all apply in
england and the devolved administrations
are taking
similar steps i spoke yesterday with
each of the first ministers
and again today and i thank them for
their
collaboration the health of everyone in
these islands depends
on our common success already
about 13 million people across england
are living under various local
restrictions
over and above national measures
we will continue to act against local
flare-ups working alongside councils
and strengthening measures where
necessary and i want to speak
directly to those who are shielding
early in the pandemic and
who may be anxious about being at
greater
risk following advice from our senior
clinicians
our guidance continues to be that you do
not
need to shield except in local lockdown
areas
and we will keep this under constant
review
i must emphasize that if all our actions
fail to bring the r below one
then we reserve the right to deploy
greater firepower
with significantly greater restrictions
i
further want to avoid taking
this step as do the devolved
administrations but we will only be able
to
avoid it if our new measures work
and our behavior changes
mr speaker we will spare no effort in
developing
vaccines treatments new forms of mass
testing
but unless we palpably make progress we
should assume
that the restrictions i have announced
will remain in place
for perhaps six months for the time
being
this virus is a fact of our lives
and i must tell the house and the
country
that our fight against it will continue
we will not listen to those who say let
the virus rip nor to those
who urge a permanent lockdown
we are taking decisive and appropriate
steps
to balance saving lives with protecting
jobs and livelihoods
i know all of this will have profound
consequences for our constituents
so the government will give the house
every opportunity
to scrutinize our decisions in addition
to regular
statements and debates honourable
members will be able to question
the government's scientific advisors
more regularly
gain access to data about their
constituencies
your constituencies and join daily
calls with my right honourable friend
the pay master general
after six months of restrictions
it would be tempting to hope that the
threat
has faded and to seek comfort in the
belief
that if you have avoided the virus so
far then you are somehow
immune i have to say
that it is that kind of complacency that
could be
our undoing if we fail
to act together now we will not only
place others
at risk but jeopardize our
own futures with the more drastic action
that we would inevitably be forced to
take
mr speaker no british government would
wish to
stifle our freedoms in the way
in the ways that we have found necessary
this year
yet even now we can draw comfort some
comfort from the fact that schools and
universities and places of worship
are staying open shops can serve their
customers
construction workers can go to building
sites and the vast
majority of the uk economy
can continue moving forward we are also
mr speaker better prepare
for a second wave with the ventilators
the ppe
the dexamethasone the nightingale
hospitals and a hundred
times as much testing as we began
this epidemic with so it now falls
to each of us and every one of us
to remember the basics wash
our hands cover our faces observe
social distancing and follow the rules
then
we can fight back against this virus
shelter our economy from even
greater damage protect the most
vulnerable
in care homes and hospitals safeguard
our nhs
and save many more lives and i commend
this statement to the house i don't call
the leader of the opposition
kia starman thank you mr speaker
i want to thank the prime minister for
advanced site of his statement
and for his telephone call last night
mr speaker the picture presented
yesterday by the government's advisors
was stark
and cannot be ignored infections are
rising
hospitalizations arising the trajectory
is clear and we know from bitter
experience
what happens next so it is right
that the prime minister is announcing
further measures today
and we support those measures just as we
supported lockdown in march
and the more recent local lockdowns
although we
fierce criticism of the way the
government is handling this pandemic
when restrictions are needed the
national interest
lies in clear communications and
cross-party support
and so we will as we've done before
encourage people to follow the
government guidance
and obey the rule of law mr speaker
families across the country will be
anxious today
many are already living under local
lockdowns
many more fear that soon they will
they're worried about their jobs
about their loved ones and whether they
will be able to spend christmas
with their families they will also be
worried
that the government doesn't have a clear
strategy
one day people are encouraged to work in
the office in fact more than encouraged
they were openly challenged by the prime
minister for not doing so
today they're told the opposite
this is a time of national crisis or we
need clear leadership
so it's right the prime is to answer a
number of serious questions about the
next steps
first a number of areas in england
already have localized restrictions
including some that are very similar to
those announced today
pubs and restaurants in bolton for
example have been told to set at 10 p.m
for about two weeks lester's been in
localized restrictions
for about three months and yet the
infections in those areas
remain high so can the prime minister be
sure that the restrictions he's
introducing today
will be effective at suppressing the
virus
and if they don't work when does he
envisage further measures
might be necessary i also want to
ask about the support for families and
businesses
these restrictions will put further
pressures on the hospitality sector
on high streets and town centres on
people's jobs and businesses
so what emergency financial support will
be made available
to those that need it there was nothing
in the prime minister's statement about
that
there's a big gap here and will he now
accept
that withdrawing the furlough scheme in
one fell scoop
would be a disaster and actually at
complete odds with the measures
he's just announced for possibly up to
six months
and will he take us up on our offer to
work with him
and trade unions and businesses on a
replacement scheme that protects jobs
and businesses mr speaker given the rise
in infections we're seeing these
restrictions
are necessary but they were not
inevitable we warned the prime minister
months ago
that testing need to be fixed by the
autumn
the academy of medical sciences told him
the same in july
they said testing and tracing capacity
will need to be significantly expanded
to cope with the increased demands over
the winter but the government didn't
listen they pretended there wasn't a
problem they didn't act quickly enough
now the testing system isn't working
just when we need it
we should also recognize that a second
national lockdown
is not inevitable that would be a a huge
failure of government
not an act of god there is still time to
prevent it
that must be a national effort labor
will do whatever is reasonable and
necessary to support that
to save lives to protect the nhs but the
government must lead
i must do so fast prime minister
well mr speaker i'm grateful to the
writers for his support there i noticed
that it
it seems to to come and go but it seems
to be it seems to be here to
it seems to be here today he criticizes
uh testing he should
he should know mr speaker that as i've
told the house
uh many times uh this country is now
testing more than any other country in
europe
uh one one test for every every five
people and
and actually uh in spite of the massive
increase in the demand for
uh for testing uh we have greatly
increased
the number of contacts that are being uh
being reached from the index cases
and i think you should pay tribute to
those who are involved in the whole
testing operation in spite of all the
difficulties
that they face he mentions the uh the
success of
local lockdowns and he's absolutely
right to draw attention to what happened
in leicester
uh and that was a heroic effort of local
people
and it's happened in other parts of the
country local people pulling together to
drive
the virus down that is what we hope to
encourage throughout the country and
that is
certainly part of our strategy he asked
mr speaker about what we're doing to
support businesses support
families and to support communities
across the country as though we hadn't
already
uh quite rightly spent 160
billion pounds mr speaker to support uh
business and jobs across the country
jobs and libraries and we will continue
to put our arms around the people of
this country
and mr speaker i'm grateful as i say for
what he has he has said for the
support such it is that he is that he
has offered
by these measures but we are also as i
said mr speaker
keeping the vast majority of the uk
economy going that is our program that
is what we intend to do
this is a package this is a package to
drive down
the r but also to allow education
and jobs and the growth to continue that
is absolutely vital
for the right honourable gentleman to
understand my hope in his
support which i welcome uh he will
communicate that uh to the country
as well let's head to amisham with dame
cheryl gillan then gerald gillan
one of the most difficult decisions a
prime minister has to take in a
democracy is to restrict our freedoms
for the greater good
and in the measures he's announced today
in the cross-party consensus i think my
right honourable friend has sought
balance and proportionality as he says
protecting the economy whilst reducing
the risk of the virus spreading like a
wildfire
but with this six-month time frame he's
announced what does he say to
grandparents who want to live their
lives before it's too late and cannot
see their families
to worried parents and families who
cannot access a test at the moment
to workers and business owners facing
financial ruin
and to mps that want to debate these
matters in parliament
before they are decided not after so
they can
help him shoulder this onerous
responsibility
how can he convince all of them that
he's taking the right path
and unite our country with hope of an
end
to this misery i thank my
right honourable friend and she's she's
entirely right that parliament
should and will uh debate these issues
and mr speaker will make
time early next week in in government
time for a full
debate on these met on these measures of
the snp
in blackfoot thank you mr speaker can i
thank the prime minister for advanced
site of his
statement mr speaker we have reached the
critical moment
the virus has not gone away it's not
going away
and it remains as deadly as ever
i welcome the fact that following calls
this weekend from our first minister
a four nation cobra meeting has taken
place this morning
we have all witnessed the warning rise
in virus cases over the last number of
weeks
and we all know that the projections and
consequences our society will face if it
continues to grow
at the same rate but we must also be
clear about one thing
if we take the right actions now there
is nothing inevitable about the
exponential spread
of this virus if we act decisively
if we move sharp
if we take the right tough decisions now
we can get the
virus back under control we can minimize
the time we all spend
under new restrictions and most
importantly we can save lives
mr speaker today governments across the
four nations
are rightly asking citizens to make more
sacrifices
to protect our collective health in
return for these sacrifices
it is only right that citizens are
provided with financial support
amid the health and economic uncertainty
mr speaker we are now just a few short
weeks away
from the end of the furlough scheme
analysis from the scottish government
has already shown that extending the
scheme by eight months could save around
61 000 jobs in scotland france germany
and ireland
have already extended their job
retention schemes
into next year but the prime minister
and the chancellor
have rigidly refused to extend furlough
but we all know that new terms and
mixed messaging have come to define this
government and
the 10th of july the prime minister said
go back to work if you can on the 14th
of august the chancellor said it was
crucial
that we do our bit such as going back to
our place of work and on the
27th of august government sources said
go back to work
or risk losing your job the prime
minister has
changed his advice this morning on
working from home it is now time
to change his mind on furlough as well
so today i have one question
and it's a question that 61 000
employees in scotland are asking
prime minister they deserve certainty
and they deserve an answer will this
government
now save these jobs and extend the
furlough scheme beyond october
prime minister do not throw workers on
the scrap heap
through no fault of their own prime
minister well mr speaker there was a
great deal in in uh right honourable
gentleman's
uh question that i i agreed with and i
think he's right that we need to take
decisive action now and i'm very
grateful for the uh the collaboration
that
we've all been engaging across across
the uk
uh our objective mr speaker is to is to
keep businesses going and to keep the
economy moving
as as much as we can and indeed uh to
allow people
uh to go back to work where they they
must but of course to work from
home if they can it's very very clear uh
what the uh what the choices are and
what the
what the guidance is and of course we
will continue
to support uh businesses we will
continue to support people
who face challenges because of
coronavirus throughout
our united kingdom and i would remind
him that
in scotland alone uh the uh the barnet
consequentials of the
of the support uh i think are now well
over five
billion pounds and across the whole of
the uk
in the devolved administrations about
12.6 billion pounds and we will continue
to send that support throughout the
whole of the uk
to put our arms around the whole of the
workforce of the uk
and to protect jobs and livelihoods but
what we also want to see
is those businesses continuing and jobs
being created
jeremy hunt thank you mr speaker i
support the measures announced today the
prime minister will have decided them
with a heavy
heart but all the evidence from south
korea singapore
and other countries is that early
decisive action now
is the best way to avoid a second full
lockdown
later i want to ask him about testing
we have triple capacity since may and
we'll double it again
by the end of october so there has been
a transformation
but we're not there yet how can he
reassure a school in my constituency
which has a child who is tested positive
but they only get a quota of ten tests
every three weeks
and they are worried that they may have
people who are passing on the virus
asymptomatically that they're not able
to identify
what would he say to them and to schools
up and down the country that are trying
so hard to do the right thing
mr speaker my right honourable friend is
is absolutely right that
we are and have massively increased
testing across the country we're now
prioritizing
uh teachers as he as he knows uh he
raises a very important point about
uh about about about school pupils and
there there is a very interesting fact
which is that actually the rates of
uh of infection and transmission amongst
school pupils are much lower
than in uh the rest of the uh of the
population but
uh i'm not going to hide it from him
that uh the future i see
for our country and the way to defeat
this virus
is massively uh to expand testing and
not just for teachers and not just for
in schools uh but throughout the country
and and that is why i'm proud
that uh nhs tests race in spite of all
the difficulties which the right old
gentleman and others have legitimately
pointed out nhs
test and trace is now conducting a more
test than any other country
in europe i think we should be we should
be proud of that mr speaker
have led to these latest restrictions on
people's daily
lives and mr speaker as families and
businesses look forward especially
to christmas how will the government
support the millions of people
who are on the brink of losing their
jobs
losing their businesses losing their
livelihoods
what is the new plan for them
prime minister mr speaker the the plan
uh is is that we should continue to keep
the economy
moving in the way that i have described
and the way that the government has set
out in which
i believe is supported by uh the
opposition quite rightly
uh while suppressing the r whilst
getting the virus down
that is our policy does he support it
yeah greg clark
thank you very much uh mr speaker one of
the lessons of the lockdown measures in
the spring
was that they worked but almost everyone
ended up wishing that they'd been
introduced
a week or two earlier so i believe the
prime minister's right
to act in anticipation rather than
in reaction but will he take the public
into his confidence
and say is the six months that he
mentioned
irrespective of the experience of
infections and hospitalization
over the weeks and months ahead and what
will be the criteria
for lifting these restrictions and
others like the rule of six
mr speaker my right hand will offend us
a really important question
and the answer is of course that we
must look at what the data tells us and
above all
uh we look at there are several
important data but uh
the r is perhaps the the crucial one but
we also look at
uh rates of emissions uh to hospitals
and uh and new infections and if those
facts
change if things uh turn around and if
the the british public can do what they
did before
and get this virus down and get it under
control then of course
we will review the measures and review
the situation
mr speaker so jeffrey donaldson thank
you mr speaker
the prime minister is right that testing
is a vital part of the government's
response to the
coronavirus and will he join me in
commanding companies like randox
and fortress diagnostics in northern
ireland who played a vital role
at national level in helping to deliver
the government's testing
program indeed randox has committed 99
of its covert testing capacity to that
program
and on the 19th of september they
successfully reported
almost 10 000 samples beyond their
committed
daily rate will the prime minister
consider providing
access to testing through local
community
pharmacies to expand the capacity
on public accessibility to testing at
this time
mr speaker i i do indeed congratulate uh
randox and
uh and all the other uh businesses
involved and
we are massively uh expanding uh testing
the whole time uh i think it's very
important for the house to understand
that
testing alone cannot fix this problem
indeed
there is a there is a hiatus in the in
the logic of
of the attacks that are sometimes
mounted uh
the problem that we have in the spread
of this virus is
that alas uh people have uh a minority
of people have not been following the
guidance in the way that
uh they might have done and what we're
trying to do now is to get
everybody uh to focus on uh those rules
on that guidance
to enforce it strictly and to get the r
down manchester united thank you mr
speaker
i thank the prime minister for all his
hard work
during these difficult challenging times
to keep
us all safe the prime minister will be
aware that i previously
put forward two private members bills to
improve mental health care provision for
all
which was supported by the royal college
of psychiatrists
this morning i spoke with professor
ellen young from king's college london
who raised with me real concerns with
regards
to the reduction in mental health care
provision
for those with severe severe mental
health issues
during covet 19. will the prime minister
please
urgently look into this matter and the
representations which i will forward to
his office
from experts such as professor young
well prime minister speak i look forward
to receiving those representations i
will study them
carefully as the house has heard before
mr speaker the government is spending 12
billion pounds
more on mental health provision uh plus
throughout this pandemic we've been
putting extra cash
into mental health charities but i will
certainly look at the
the case that he raises this suffer
robert
at the start of the pandemic there were
concerns that visitors were gathering in
crowds at
beauty spots like her with snowden this
happened again last weekend
local lockdowns in wales now require
people to remain within their local
authority area except
for essential reasons no such
requirement exists in england
in those unfortunate situations where
people face local lockdowns will he give
clear guidance against out of trouble
out of area travel
for leisure purposes prime minister uh
well mr speaker
for local lockdowns the guidance is
given uh by the local authorities
uh following the decision in coburdo
about exactly
uh what restrictions are to be placed
but clearly the the restriction she
faces is
uh she suggests is part of the myth
steve brian
i thank the prime minister for his
statement and for being here today
in person answering our questions surely
the reality
prime minister is that national lockdown
has one shot
and any repeat of that with the
inevitable unlock
that follows reintroduces an increased
element of opportunity for the virus
and then risk for us as we're seeing now
so would the prime minister agree
that all of these restrictions on our
constituents lives
require their ongoing consent and it's
incumbent on government
the scientists who advise him and
parliament
to stress test these decisions and
crucially the evidence that lies behind
them
yeah minister uh well mr speaker i i do
agree with that and i think it will be
greatly to the advantage of
uh the debate into the country uh for
these questions to be
uh discussed in the in the house in the
way that i've outlined
earlier and already proposed by uh our
writer
before the member for amisham caroline
lucas
thank you mr speaker the public has
shown a vast capacity for putting others
first during this pandemic
and now they're being asked to do more
but in return the government needs to do
more for them
public consent is dependent on not being
forced into financial ruin
so will he ensure that the sector's most
affected like hospitality in the arts
continue to get the financial support
that they need and in particular
will he meet with me and other honorable
members to find solutions
for over three million self-employed
people who have not been covered by
existing financial schemes he says he's
going to put his arms around the whole
workforce
many millions of the self-employed have
not felt the benefit of that
embrace prime minister mr speaker
she raises an important point and we
have uh extended
loans uh grants uh to every conceivable
sector of the
uh of the economy and we will we will do
well 1.57 billion to the uh to the arts
sector uh alone
uh which that she mentions and we will
of course uh we will of course do more
but
the most important thing we can do is
return to the the central message i'm
trying to
get over today is that we've got to push
down on the r
while simultaneously allowing as much of
the economy to flourish
as we possibly can and that is the uh
our collective
uh objective today speaker the country
is now full of amateur infection control
experts amateur epidemiologist the old
captain hindsight and i don't tend to be
one of those
but i must express to him the concern of
constituents in my area where our
seven day rolling average is now well
below 20 and falling
where people have followed the rules
have seen people at protests at street
parties
not having action taken against them but
we will now suffer as a result of these
further measures to support them though
i do and in particular hospitality will
suffer
so can i urge him to look again at the
government's plans to halve
the small brewers rate relief which will
damage uh small brewers particularly
craft brewers
and can we look again at that this is
not the time to be introducing such
changes
uh well mr speaker he speaks eloquently
my friend speaks eloquently for his
uh constituents and those uh who feel
let down by the minority who are not
enforcing
and not obeying the rules that's why
we're outlining this program
of tough enforcement uh today
and i will certainly look at the uh i
will certainly ask my writer
for the chancellor uh to look at the uh
fiscal measures that he uh proposes in
respect of small brewers
stephen thank you mr speaker the prime
minister will have support for taking
the necessary measures
uh to contain and suppress the virus but
he is receiving a very strong message
from both sides of the house today
that he does need to revisit the
economic support measures
particularly in light of changed
circumstances and bearing in mind
the need to look at other creative and
innovative solutions
so therefore will he accept whenever the
chancellor made a statement
back at the beginning of july there was
a certain set
of planning assumptions those no longer
apply with the virus
therefore it is incompetent the doctor
to change course what they're doing to
support people as well
prime minister mr speaker i i i
acknowledge the point that the
honourable general has made and it's
certainly our intention
uh as we go forward to do everything we
can as i've said to protect
our lives livelihoods put our arms
around
everyone in this country i think no one
could deny that uh
the chancellor has been exceptionally
creative and ambitious in the plans that
he's set out
and he will continue to apply the
maximum possible
imagination and creativity in this
respect
nick fletcher thank you don valley
appreciates all the work the prime
minister and his team are carrying out
in response to the recent rise in the
case
of covert 19. that said i must say to my
right honourable friend
that blanket restrictions are affecting
all people of all ages
and material the actual risk posed to
them could the government therefore not
ask individuals to carry out a personal
carbon risk assessment
the results of which could determine
whether someone needs to shield or can
go about their daily lives
this will help boost the economy while
protecting the vulnerable
after all many people's lives are being
affected tremendously by these
restrictions especially the young
who as we all know are only young once
prime minister mr speaker my honorable
friend really puts his
finger on the heart of the of the
problem of the of the dilemma
because of course uh the the tragedy of
the coronavirus epidemic is that people
uh who are not badly affected themselves
can nonetheless
pass it on unwittingly uh to older or
more vulnerable people so
uh your harmless cough can be someone
else's
death now unfortunately and that is why
we have to
apply the restrictions uh that we do but
he's right also
uh to look ahead uh to a time when i do
believe we will be able
uh much more easily to identify mr
speaker whether or not
uh we are infectious and to allow us
therefore to go back to our daily lives
more easily young and old general jones
thank you mr speaker
by 6 p.m this evening both local
authorities covering my constituency
will be under welsh government local
lockdown restrictions
aimed at slowing the spread of the virus
among the restrictions will be a
restriction on holiday travel meaning
that constituents will not be able to
go on on planned holidays and some uh
holiday companies are refusing refunds
on the grounds that local restrictions
are not covered by uk law
uh and pointing instead to foreign and
commonwealth office
advice on travel so what can the prime
minister do to support constituents in
this case and what is
his message to those holidays
mr speaker he asked an excellent
question and uh
it's not an anomaly that i'd i hated to
been aware of but
uh if you would care to write to me uh
with the details of his constituents
uh concerns i will certainly uh take it
up gratia
thank you thank you mr speaker mr
speaker derrick valley hospital in my
constituency did an amazing job at the
heart
of the outbreak as did many of my local
gp surgeries however they were under
huge pressure
therefore would the prime minister
consider extending the ability of local
pharmacies
and chemists to administer health
treatment so
these gems on our high street are able
to ease the pressure on our health
system
i thank my honourable friend and he's
completely right that pharmacies and
chemists are in the front line of our
health care and do
an absolutely outstanding job uh in
testing
uh people for all kinds of things uh
covered
uh amongst them and we will certainly
support them in any way that we can
let's head to kenny caskell in scotland
kenny mccaskill
you mr speaker we may well have to
endure for six months or more
but it's less than six weeks until
furlough scheme ends
germany france and even ireland are
extending furlough schemes for specific
sectors
it's a political not a health decision
many communities in my constituency were
devastated by political decisions
made by a tory government in the 1980s
that wrecked mass unemployment are they
now to have that
revisited upon them in 2020
or will the prime minister extend the
furlough scheme
prime minister uh well mr speaker the
comparisons with other european
countries are actually
uh illuminating uh because the furlough
scheme was far more generous than
uh either germany or france uh or
virtually any other country
uh in in europe and uh what we will
continue to do
is as i said repeatedly to the house is
to put our arms
around the workers of this country to
make sure that we help people throughout
the
the crisis but also as i have told you
before mr speaker
to do everything we can to keep our
economy moving and keep people
in work wherever we can let's head down
to devon with mel stride
mill stride thank you uh mr speaker i
very much welcome the balanced and
proportionate set of measures that my
writer or
friend has put together and also
recognize that these are very finely
balanced and very difficult
decisions for him to take but lockdowns
as i think my right honourable friend
recognizes destroy jobs and also
personal well-being
and the fact that lockdowns have damaged
our economy means that in the years
ahead a smaller economy
will probably have serious impacts on
the health of millions of people
up and down our country so does my right
honourable friend recognize that yes we
should listen very carefully to the
epidemiologists
but we must also listen very carefully
to the treasury
to businesses and to economists too
prime minister
mr speaker my normal friend is spot on
uh that's why we have to take
uh action now uh to avoid uh the
the risk of having to take more drastic
action uh later on
uh that would do greater economic damage
and
uh and that is the the key point of what
we're doing today
we're heading up to kingston hill with
dame diner johnson
named diana thank you thank you mr
speaker can the prime minister explain
why a new test centre
opening today on whole university land
for students
and the local community and one of
course of which i welcome
will be run by private firms deloitte
and g4s with no
accountability to local bodies with
statutory public health responsibilities
for the local community
or the university who are of course
responsible
for their students how does this silo
approach
that the prime minister has created
around testing
help us to have a joined up approach
that we all want in hull to tackle this
pandemic
prime minister mr speaker i will study
what she says about
uh the testing unit in in hull
university but everywhere across
the country uh nhs test and trace has
been working hand in glove
uh with local authorities to get testing
done working hand in glove
uh with public health england of course
uh with all
our public services and i'm i'm
surprised by what she says
about uh the testing unit at hull
university but i will certainly
ask nhs test and trace to give her a
full
explanation but in my experience
everything is done to enlist
and mobilize the expertise of local
government
uh to get the testing done richard
fuller
uh thank you mr speaker many people are
concerned with this dominant focus on
kobe that people who need nhs treatment
for other illnesses or seeking elective
surgery
are going to be pushed further back in
the queue so can the prime minister
assure us
and make sure that the health secretary
gives a priority to communicating
the progress in dealing with the backlog
in these surgeries as we go through the
winter period
right minister thank you very much mrs b
i i i
of course we must do everything we can
uh to um
ensure that our nhs is not overwhelmed
uh with coded
cases and it's it's when you have a
crisis a copied
crisis a boom in kobe cases that as he
rightly points out
other needs other cardiac cancer
cases are are pushed off and that is
completely wrong and that's why
it is so vital now uh that we suppress
the r that we drive
the rate of infection and we stop a boom
uh in covered cases because that is the
the threat to our nhs and to the
provision of all the basic services
on which our our country relies correct
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's objective does rely on the
local public health effort and i want to
thank the local nhs in bristol bristol
city council and public health england
in the southwest for the remarkable work
they are doing but reorganizing health
services
always distracts from their job it
destroys morale
and it wastes money so can the prime
minister explain to us the benefits of
abolishing public health england
in the middle of this crisis and if
absolutely essential that we have the
most powerful uh
possible uh public health organization
in this country and
the national biosecurity center now
needs to come together
uh with public health england to to to
deliver
what i believe will be a better service
uh for this country in fact the
the change to which she refers doesn't
happen until
next year but we're getting it underway
now
thank you mr speaker i know the prime
minister is truly libertarian and he
must have agonized over the
decision uh of today and over recent
months but my constituents in meridian
are
however concerned about a second
national lockdown about schools closing
about businesses
shutting down so does my right
honourable friend agree that individual
responsibility is more important today
than it's ever been
and will he confirm that he will do
everything he can to avoid a second full
national lockdown
and mr speaker i thank my honourable
friend the whole objective
today is to avoid that uh second
national lockdown nobody uh wants to to
see that and he's indeed right to
to to point the finger
the way we uh the way we act in in
public places
that is how we will get the r down
collectively
and defeat the virus thank you mr
speaker mr speaker back in july the
government introduced
the planning and uh the paying bill
which allowed
the sale of alcohol off the premises and
the consumption off the premises for as
long as the license of those licensed
premises
today just a weeks later the prime
minister's come to the house
saying that we there will be no sales no
service in hospitality
after 10 o'clock at night can he explain
the rationale
behind that 10 o'clock curfew and the
very fast turn of
of change of plan by the government
minister
she's raising a very important point and
i'm i'm grateful for the and
you know as as members have said across
the house these are not easy decisions
nobody wants to be
curtailing uh the right of restaurants
and other businesses to
to go about their lawful business uh
what we've seen from the evidence is
that alas
uh the spread of the disease does tend
to happen uh later at night
after a more alcohol has been consumed
this is one way
that we see of driving down the air
without doing excessive
economic damage and that's that's the
balance we have to strike heading up to
filed in lancashire with mark menzies
mark menzies
thank you mr speaker um can i welcome
the measures that the right honourable
friend the prime minister has laid
before the house today
can also say to them that people who are
vulnerable to coverts are also extremely
vulnerable to seasonal flu
a disease that's killed over 11 000
people last year in the uk alone
but is also one of the biggest sources
of winter pressures upon the nhs
in the sum of the government promise one
of the largest flu vaccination programs
in history
comrade honourable friend update the
house and what's been done to deliver
this
minister uh yes indeed i can mr speak i
can tell uh
the uh my honorable friend that the uh
the
biggest flu vaccine program is uh going
ahead
as we speak and uh 30 million people
uh will be able to have a flu jab this
autumn and i
thoroughly advise uh members uh to get
one
heading up to livingston to hannah
bardell hannah bardell
thank you very much mr speaker there is
a wee whiff of hypocrisy
because as the prime minister and his
cabinet bring in new measures to come
back covered 19
prime minister needs to tell us how he
expects citizens across the uk
to follow his rules and laws when he and
his government are openly admitting that
they are willing to break international
law
and treaties
be the people of this country and to
help the people of this country
to obey the law of the land and to get
the virus down
and that is the objective of this
government dr caroline johnson
thank you mr speaker mr speaker children
are very unlikely to be harmed by this
virus
but and they're also less likely to
spread it but in my roles as a
children's doctor
as a member of the education select
committee and as a constituency mp
i've seen examples of where children
have been harmed by not being in school
can my righteous friend the prime
minister reassure this house that he
will do
everything within his power to keep
schools open
prime minister yes mr speaker and i want
to thank
her for what she does but also the
millions of uh
go back to school and in overwhelming
numbers they are still at school in
spite of the difficulties
uh that they are currently facing and if
she is so right it is vital
for children young people to be in
school and we will do everything
in our power to ensure that that remains
the case
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will no doubt be aware
of the alarming rate at which
coronavirus cases
are rising among bame groups and in
particular among the asian population
with some 34 of coronavirus patients in
intensive care
right now being from ethnic minorities
so could he
this worrying trend and what action has
his government taken
uh to uh tackle the disproportionate
impact on ethnic minorities since ph
published its report in june
possibly already is that we have
targeted uh
testing and protection
uh the risks of transmission and the
basic rules about hands
face uh space that's that's among
the things that we're doing heading down
to chatham to tracy crouch
tracy thank you mr speaker
sport and physical activity contributes
over 16 billion pounds to the uk economy
it directly employs over 600 000 people
and indirectly many more it has an
ecosystem that reaches beyond the pitch
field quarter pool
pool and its social value which includes
physical and mental well-being is
estimated at more than 72 billion pounds
and yet right now both coats of rugby
football cricket netball hockey tennis
swimming today but a few
are in a perilous situation due to
spectators not being able to
return and venues unable to host income
raising events such as conferences
sport and all it directly and indirectly
involves cannot continue to face these
kind of losses
so given today's announcement which
causes the return of space
the support package to ensure that it
isn't left
decimated after the pandemic prime
minister
uh well my right honourable friend is
absolutely right to draw attention
to the huge importance of sport to
our national uh economy and uh
to the on our well-being and that's why
uh my right on friends extra state for
culture media and support is now working
uh flat out with the premier league and
others to identify ways in which we can
keep
uh these clubs going we can support uh
sport at all levels
uh throughout the pandemic and one of
the things that we're we're not
doing uh as she will appreciate today is
we're not stopping
uh outdoor physical exercise or not
stopping
uh team sports outside we want that uh
to continue
but that's why it's vital that we
enforce the the package
of measures that we have outlined today
great boys
thank you mr speaker and you'll be aware
of the
recent imposition of further
restrictions
in the northeast of england so first of
all can i thank the prime minister for
listening
and acting upon concerns both
individually and collectively from the
northern group
of labour mps about informal child care
arrangements
uh in my constituency and others however
before he feels my warm embrace can i
can i ask him in relation to the latest
to the latest announcement on
restrictions on businesses
can i ask him to provide assurances to
businesses
in my constituency by outlining what
sector-specific support his government
will offer
to those worst affected by corvid such
as the court sector
which is on the brink of collapse due to
government inaction in the main
and the failure to listen to the hong
kong campaign
prime minister uh we will we will do
whatever we can to support the coach
sector and indeed
uh all other uh sectors across the
country we
we we as he knows uh put into place a
massive
uh program of loans of grants
and support of all kind but uh it is
clear
that the the best thing for uh
businesses in his
constituency and across the country is
not to paralyze the economy now and not
to
go back into lockdown but to defeat the
virus insofar as we possibly can
and allow the economy uh to move forward
but we will continue
to give whatever help we can think baker
mr speaker i'm thankful for my
right-wing friends
commitments on parliamentary scrutiny
he'll know many members of the house and
of the public are concerned about the
use
of delegated powers and i'm sure he'll
remember the sifting committee from the
eu withdrawal act
could i invite him to please consider
whether some innovative thinking can be
applied to
make sure that the authority of this
house is brought to bear in advance on
these measures
so that the public can have confidence
that their representatives are
authorizing
uh the use of of of law to constrain
their freedom
prime minister yes mr speaker under the
current procedures it is up to the house
to
uh to confirm that the uh the executive
does have the power to continue
uh uh with measures under the
coronavirus act and that will
uh continue uh to be the case and we are
additionally uh
offering uh insisting mr speaker that
there should be
a proper debate of these issues in
parliament because there are many
different opinions in parliament and
i think people need to air them together
thank you mr speaker children were
delighted to return to their primary
schools earlier
this month but not surprisingly after
six months of isolation
coughs and coals have spread rapidly
amongst them since and we've been
reminded that each primary school has
just
10 covid tests so when will primary
schools have the wherewithal to test
children and staff
with symptoms to avoid spreading the
virus at school and also avoid
unnecessary
school closures prime minister well mr
speaker he's he's spot-on about what's
been happening with
uh in schools and and sadly i think uh
in in many cases we've seen a a rise in
the demand for
the tests uh because people are
reasonably unable to distinguish between
the symptoms of of coming or seasonal
uh cough or or cold uh we're trying to
address it as
as fast as we possibly can but the one
consolation we have in this is
two things children uh are much less
likely to suffer
seriously from the uh disease if at all
and they're much
uh less capable it seems of spreading it
thank you mr speaker i thank the prime
minister for his statement and for his
steadfast service to our country during
this very
difficult time the prime minister
understands the long-term harm a second
lockdown would cause to people across
the country to their health their lives
their livelihoods
as they try their very best to get back
on their feet
will the prime minister consider
targeting protective measures
for those most at risk rather than
deploying the blunt instrument
which is locked down which we know
causes so much suffering
and which offers no hope of a cure prime
minister well mr speaker she's right
about both things and
uh we're we are doing everything we can
to protect particularly those in
in care homes who are uh so vulnerable
as we saw in the early stages of this
pandemic and we've uh massively
increased the
uh the winter plan action plan for the
care homes another 546 million
uh gone in stopping uh movement between
care homes and taking the very tough
decision uh to stop
uh visits to care homes in in lockdown
areas which is very
very difficult for elderly people who
are uh you know in a care home
uh and the reason that we're taking
those measures
and now there's those difficult measures
now mr speaker is because
we want to avoid another national
lockdown of exactly the type
that she rightly wants to avoid
thank you mr speaker some of my
constituents have been waiting
four days five days or even longer to
get their test results back the
government rightly
promised in july that 80
of in-person tests would get their
results in 24 hours from booking
that is now down to below 20
that is dangerous it means people are
not in the tracing system
it means their contacts aren't being
traced it makes it easier for the virus
to spread
and it makes it more likely that we will
face even tougher restrictions that the
prime minister has described
across the whole country so given that
the government
made so many mistakes on testing in the
first wave
we cannot afford for him to get this
wrong again now
when will that 80 target now be met
well mr speaker uh in spite of the
massive increase
in uh testing that we've seen uh
10 increase in capacity just in the last
uh 10 days or so
we are uh seeing at the moment 64
percent of people getting
uh their results in uh in 24 hours uh
and
i do want to get that up as fast as
possible uh to 80 percent
uh what i can tell her is that we will
double our testing capacity
by the end of october to 500 000
tests a day and we are already testing
more people than any other country in
europe
permission to land the question bob
lightman
thank you mr speaker and i welcome my
right on a friend's
statement and clear statement of purpose
to conquer this terrible virus
one of the key concerns locally however
has been the failure to comply
with regulations of wearing a face
covering
in shops and on public transport clearly
with these new
restrictions coming to place one of the
key issues is going to make sure
going to be sure that people actually
comply with these requirements
equally people do not want to get to a
position whereby
they're forced to wear a face covering
in the open air just going about their
normal business
can my writer or friend state for the
house what he's going to do to make sure
that the message gets across to people
that failing to comply with these rules
is really selfish and and potentially
placing other people
at risk prime minister uh well my
honourable friend is spot on and that's
why we're increasing the fines from 100
pounds
uh to 200 pounds you're protecting
yourself you're protecting other people
you wear a face covering while you
should
and into leads with richard bergen
richard bergen
thank you mr speaker shamefully the uk
has had one of the highest chronovirus
death rates in the world
if we'd had germany's deaths per million
rates
we'd have over 30 000 fewer coronavirus
deaths if we'd had
the much lower death rate of south korea
and new zealand
we'd have over 40 000 fewer deaths
so will the prime minister take
responsibility
for our unacceptably high death rate
and to avoid a repeat this winter will
he now pursue the zero kerbid strategy
the independent sage is calling for and
that countries like south korea
and new zealand are successfully
implementing
prime minister mr speaker what were uh
pursuing with the
uh support of the opposition is a policy
of driving
uh this virus down uh whilst allowing uh
our education
and our economy uh to continue and i
hope that
uh he will lend his support to that
effort as well paul bristow
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
prime minister for his statement and for
his leadership during this crisis
but will he also commit to a vote in
this house
prior to any further steps towards a
full second
national lockdown
uh mr speaker i i thank my uh honorable
friend for his
uh his question we are continuing uh to
expand
uh testing and uh and tracing and it is
by
driving down this virus that we will i
believe be able to
uh take the country forward uh to a much
much brighter future and
uh it's if people focus on the measures
that we've outlined today
uh particularly on uh paying the
guidance for
social distancing that together we will
defeat uh cabling
heading to scotland with peter graham
peter graham
thank you mr speaker it's clear this
afternoon that there's a significant
level of agreement across the house that
the
restrictions the prime minister has
announced although not necessarily
popular
are necessary there's also a great deal
of cross-path to agreement
the support schemes for businesses need
to be extended at the same time as
restrictions are extended so can i ask
the prime minister
rather than simply rejecting out of hand
to agree to the invitation
to speak to business leaders to trade
union leaders and
opposition parties to put together a
financial support scheme
not only for those employees who
currently rely on fellow
but for the tens of thousands of small
business owners who have been left
without any support at all
during the last six months prime
minister uh
mr speaker i've uh had uh the
opportunity in the course last
few months to talk to many businesses up
and down the country
uh across uh scotland and uh
they have been uniformly appreciative of
the support that the government has
has given so far i must say and we will
ensure
as i said earlier on that we will
maintain a very creative and imaginative
approach
uh in uh in helping those businesses but
the best thing we can do
is uh fight the virus and keep the
economy moving
great thomas thank you mr speaker and i
thank the pm for his statement and he is
right to say that he is the cooperation
and good sense
of the british public that has saw the
spread of this difficult outbreak
curtailed
my constituents will continue to do
exactly what's required of them
but the truth is that corman has a very
low rate of covered 90 and this has been
the case throughout
so what message of hope can the prime
minister give to
teenagers who are going to score on
colleges being asked to wear face masks
when not in class to church goers who
are being blocked from freedom of
worship
and to businesses who have yet to open
and are continually frustrated
from doing so well mr speaker church
goes i don't think you should
the church goes we will continue to have
a freedom of worship under these uh
under these proposals and we want the
econ we want
life as far as we possibly can to keep
going
uh the as normally as possible we want
the economy
to keep moving but what i think the best
hope i can offer
uh to his uh constituencies who
he fights so valiantly is that we get
this virus
back under control and take the country
forward and keep the
economy moving and that is uh the best
prospect for our country
does he think that the reason germany
and italy have
far lower covert rates than us with life
continuing more or less
normally might be because they have
locally
and publicly run test and trace services
that actually work
no mr speaker i don't and i think the
continual attacks on
uh local test and trace and uh what the
uh nhs test and trace have done
are are undermining and unnecessary
and actually there is an important
difference between our country and many
other countries around the world that is
our country is a freedom-loving country
mr speaker and if you look at the
history of this country over the last
300 years uh virtually every advance in
from free speech to democracy
uh to uh have been has come from this
has come from this country
and it is very difficult to ask the
british population uh uniformly
to obey to obey
uh guidelines in the way that it is
necessary what we're saying today
is that collectively i'm answering
answering his question directly
collectively the way to do this the way
to do this
is for us all to follow the guidelines
which we will strictly
uh enforce and get the r down that's the
way forward
rob roberts thank you mr speaker
appreciating the frustrations for people
who currently have symptoms and
i'm finding it difficult to get tests
currently with my writing friend agree
with me that capacity
going up by over 10 in the last few
weeks four new labs coming online
and hundreds of additional staff we can
reach our target of half a million tests
a day by the end of october
and would he agree with me that it would
be an amazing achievement against a
virus that we were only first learning
about a few short months ago
mr speaker i i do you will not surprise
my
honourable friend to know that i
fervently agree with uh the way he
uh characterizes uh the achievements of
nhs tests and traits and i think that
his
uh his optimism and his encouragement of
nhs test and trace could
uh could you know with uh reasonably be
echoed
on the bench's opposite heading up to
greater manchester with absol khan
absolute calm
thank you mr speaker manchester is home
to two of the largest universities in
the country with a combined student body
of nearly 80
000 many of whom choose to live in my
constituency of manchester gautam
with so many students returning to the
area
this is an incredibly difficult time for
the community
the students and their families who are
concerned for their safety
with the surge in infections and the
second way of knowing evident
what advice does the government intend
on giving to universities
on keeping their students staff and the
wider community
safe prime minister thank you
gentlemen uh the most important thing is
that uh the students who are now back at
university in in large numbers uh should
like everybody else
uh follow the guidelines and it's also
important mr speaker but
where there are outbreaks in uh
universities
uh that students should not uh be going
home uh to
uh infect their older relatives you
merriman
thank you mr speaker the districts of
wielding and rather that comprise my
constituency
have recorded in the last week just four
copied
uh conditions per 100 000 population
each
can i ask the prime minister he said
that palpable progress will need to be
made
if this is not to last for six months in
terms of his new
measures can i ask him to consider
whether those areas that have
lower rates will be freed from these
restrictions perhaps earlier
if progress is indeed made across the
nation well of course mr speaker and
that's why i thank
my uncle that's why we're confiding uh
our hopes and our confidence in a
in a in a local uh regional approach
rather than
a blanket one-size-fits-all national
approach
and uh we hope to be uh
and when we hope that those areas that
are complying with the rules and
those people there's many many vast
majorities that are complying with the
rules
uh will uh be able to see uh the
opportunity that he describes
sarasota thank you mr speaker the prime
minister calls it nhs
test and trace but wouldn't it be more
accurate to call it circo
testing trace it has been outsourced
like other health contracts
often to friends and family members of
tory mps lying in their pockets while
taking the public for a ride
in spite of its record of failure last
week circo was handed another test and
chase contract
worth 45 million pounds mr speaker these
giant corporations put private profit
before public health
isn't it time to end the scandal of
outsourcing
and bring these contracts into public
hands for a genuine nhs test and trace
i i have to say i think she's grossly uh
undermining the huge effort of local
authorities that are an integral part
of nhs test and trace they're doing a
magnificent job i thank each and every
uh one of those individuals for what
they are they are doing and
we're putting another 300 million pounds
into supporting a local authorities
deliver
test and trace and of course it's right
that we should reach out across
the entire uh uk economy to help with
any
the armed services to help us deliver on
this enormous project and we'll continue
to do so douglas ross
thank you very much mr speaker i welcome
the work that's been done across the
four nations
in recent days as people expect our
governments to work together and unite
as we tackle this virus but given these
restrictive measures could be with us
across the uk for the next six months or
longer
what guarantee can the prime minister
give that this uk government will
continue to support
scottish employers and workers in areas
affected by these measures
when the furlough scheme ends yes prime
minister well
i i thank my uh honorable friend and as
i've said
to scottish colleagues uh across the
house uh we will continue to put our
arms around
uh workers and firms businesses around
jobs across the country
and uh that's why the the furlough
scheme uh
was was rolled out the most imaginative
and most generous of any such scheme
in europe and as i said we're providing
uh
for every person in uh scotland uh
an extra 1200 pounds uh to help fight
coronavirus and
uh 5.3 billion more announced
uh just this summer alone so mr speaker
the people of scotland uh and the people
of the whole uk
can count on this government to stand by
them throughout
the crisis jim shannon i think the prime
minister for has stepped in the day but
can the prime minister confirm that
scheduled surgeries
such as hip replacement removal of
tonsils cancer surgeries
diabetic screening and treatment will
continue with high standards
of protection and peace and that we will
not see people falling through the gaps
and those in the long waiting list will
be reduced
yes the whole objective of trying to
prevent another
boom in uh coronavirus uh suffering a
boom in coronavirus patients
is to uh to protect the nhs and to allow
uh scheduled surgery of the kind
he describes to continue jonathan gus
thank you mr speaker unfortunately in
stoke-on-trent north carolina's all
schools such as the xl academy and
almost horizon academy have staff and
students testing positive for
coronavirus
would my right honourable friend share
my concerns about staff and students
being away from the classroom as their
weight testing
and would he agree with me that school
should be prioritized for testing to
ensure both staff and students are back
in the classroom as soon as possible
uh yes indeed mr speaker and i i i want
to
uh thank uh student staff and students
in his constituency and across the
country for the
99.9 of schools that are now
uh back open again uh the vast majority
of
uh pupils uh back in their schools uh
they should have
confidence to be there and they're in
the right place it's by far the best
place for them to be and we are sending
out new test kits uh the whole time
uh and there is an online portal uh for
it but through which every school
can now access the tests that they need
kim johnson
thank you mr speaker liverpool begins
local lockdown measures today
when restrictions were first imposed six
months ago the prime minister
outlined a package of financial support
for local government
we did all that was asked of us but we
have now been left with the 23 million
pound funding gap what support is the
prime minister
able to announce today for hard hit
councils
well mr speakers i've told the honorable
lady before i believe uh
we we put about 3.7 billion pounds into
supporting
uh local government we'll continue uh to
support local government and i'll i'll
look at the
the 23 million funding gap that she
raises with me today
thank you mr speaker while working from
home has been
great for many for senior managers
living in larger properties with
nice gardens that hasn't been the
experience for a great many others
living in
cramped overcrowded accommodations so
does my retinal friend
recognize that there will be dismay
today amongst those people for whom
a return to the to covet secure
workplaces
have been so important for mental
physical
social well-being and it feels like it
will be a long six months
months for them having to work back in
their own homes
mr speaker i i thank my friend but it's
very important that you should not
misunderstand what we're
we're saying today uh where people must
go into work for the for their job for
their mental health for their well-being
or whatever it happens to be
and then of course they should do so
what we're saying is that you should
work from home
if you can i hope that he appreciates
the distinction and give his
constituents that reassurance
heading up to scotland with marion
fellows marine fellows
thank you mr speaker the chancellor
pledged at the start of this crisis
that the uk government would do whatever
it takes to help people
the prime minister has said today that
he will put his arms around the workers
of this country
so if these statements are to be
believed will the prime minister commit
to extending the furlough
to save jobs in motherwell and russia
and across the uk
and for those not in work will he make
permanent
the 20-pound uplift to universal credit
and extend this uplift to all legacy
benefits
uh uh well i'm glad mr speaker that she
draws attention to the increase in
uh universal credit uh probably worth
about four thousand pounds to
uh the poorest families in our in our
country
i'm proud of what we've done also on the
uh on the living wage and i i can tell
her that of course we will continue to
support people
across this country but the most
important thing uh to repeat my point mr
speaker is for
uh the economy to keep moving for jobs
to be created
and for people to get back into work
thank you uh mr speaker my corn valley
constituency as part of kirkleese goes
back into local restrictions today
and mr speaker we've just heard about
these new measures which may last up to
six months
taking us through the busy christmas
period can i ask the prime minister
to ask the chancellor if he will now lay
out
a financial support package for
hospitality
the likes of the wedding industry uh
marquee companies small breweries
freelance musicians and performers uh
even event venues and many many more
whose
livelihoods will be impacted by the
measures he's announced today uh well
mr speaker the sectors that he refers to
have been
many uh respects already been uh
provided for and supported but
clearly there will be further uh demands
and i know that to my right or
the friend the chancellor will be
applying uh as i say his imagination and
his
creativity to helping those sectors uh
in the months ahead but the best thing
for them
is to get back to life as to
as close to normal as possible by
getting this virus down and
and and that is the point of the package
of measures
that we're announcing today venue mishra
thank you mr speaker last week i
received a letter from the health
minister informing me
that a new covet testing center would be
available for my stockport constituents
some 240 miles away at the university of
greenwich campus in kent
once i'm willing to accept that this may
have been an administrative error
it is entirely possible that the letter
is accurate given many of my
constituents are already having to
travel
more than 70 miles away for a test in
telford
isn't it time that this got this
government got to grip and provided
comprehensive testing like our partner
countries
or will its shambolic handling of this
pandemic once again
lead to the highest covert death toll in
europe in the imminent
second wave mr speaker i'm afraid i must
correct his
uh his his figures we're not testing
more than any other country in
in europe and the median journey uh is i
think about 5.8 miles and no journey
uh is permitted to be more than 75 miles
so
uh i i don't recognize the figures uh
that i've heard from him
chris thank you mr speaker my
constituency haywood and middleton is
one of several under local measures and
has been several weeks
so i'd like to pay uh tribute to my
constituents businesses individuals and
families who have made
great sacrifices to keep this company
safe so in welcoming today's statement
can i ask the prime minister for an
assurance that this represents a circuit
break and not a hard wiring of policy
and as this is reviewed uh we will
follow all the scientific data to make
sure we get back to normal as soon as
possible
mr speaker well the intention of these
measures is collectively
to depress the r but to keep the economy
and education
functioning that's what we're trying to
do ending up to get
will he also confirm what additional
support he will put in place for
businesses and workers in the northeast
in sectors where activity has been
greatly reduced
by covert restrictions he's he's
completely right in what he says about
the areas currently in
in local lockdown measures and we are
of course doing uh extra uh giving them
extra support uh to to get them through
lockdown as as you would expect
thank you mr speaker will my right
honourable friend join me in thanking
all those who are on the front line at
the kovig 19 test centers and then the
labs working
so incredibly hard to keep up with the
unprecedented demand as we grow our
testing capacity
to 500 000 a day by the end of october
yes indeed mr speaker and i i thank each
and every one of the people involved in
nhs test and trace i think that they're
doing an outstanding job in spite of the
massive
increase in demand and i'm delighted
that she's paid a tribute to them
just now thank you mr speaker
how does the prime minister justify
recent reports
that every child at eaton gets a covert
test while currently 10
of children and staff at dual blowers
nursery in luton
are having to stay at home and isolate
why they wait for tests that show no
sign of coming
can he tell us how many school children
are currently self-isolating because
they cannot afford
to buy their own tests and if there's so
much spare capacity
why is it that not every child can get a
test when they need it
mr speaker every every child with
symptoms
should automatically get a test and
that is and that is everybody with
symptoms should get a test
and i can tell her that we are massively
expanding testing
across the country and i but i repeat
the points that i made earlier on it's
one of the
uh the few uh things for which we can be
thankful about this
epidemic that it does affect uh children
and young people
uh the youngest of all much less than uh
older people
and there is much less evidence that
they pass it on
in the way that other people do thank
you mr speaker does my right honourable
friend agree
with me that the best way to support our
heroic staff at russell's hall hospital
in dudley
our care staff and indeed our residents
in our care homes
is to actually reinforce the central
message of washing our hands
maintain social distancing and wear face
covering where appropriately yeah yeah
um mr speaker he puts it my
friend puts it uh very well and very
succinctly and i really
uh couldn't uh add him into what he said
holidays
thank you mr speaker one of the most
shocking aspects of the coronavirus
pandemic has been the disproportionate
impact on black asian and minority
ethnic residents
when public health impact public health
england published a report documenting
this
injustice the government was warned that
it needed to act
immediately to stop further preventable
deaths
but we have seen no urgency and the
chair of the british medical association
is now warning
that government in action will lead to
more preventable deaths of black asian
and minority ethnic residents
over the winter what is the prime
minister going to do about it
mr speaker i already mentioned earlier
on that we have done
a great deal to target measures to
protect
those in in front line jobs including
many uh
from uh blacker minority ethnic groups
by thanking i pay tribute
to those uh public servants many of them
who have done such a fantastic job
throughout this crisis at great personal
risk and i i really thank them for what
they're doing we are doing everything we
can
to protect them and of course where
there are
vulnerable communities uh that uh need
to understand the guidance about
coronavirus we're doing
everything we can to get the messages
home and and
those are just some of the things the
government is doing
thank you mr speaker could my right
honourable friend say to what extent the
measures he has announced today are
being coordinated with the devolved
administrations
i raised the issue because in wales the
different arrangements have sometimes
been the cause of
confusion uh not least because most
world trade
residents take their news from the
london-based media
uh well mr speaker actually over the
last uh few weeks and
months there's been exceptionally high
degree of collaboration between
the uk government and all the devolved
administrations and
uh today yesterday i had good
conversations with
uh mark drakeford uh about what he's
doing and it bears an uncanny
resemblance uh to what the uh the rest
of the uk is doing
olivia play speaker clarity is key
to public trust many people have been
confused by the government's mixed
messages on public health measures
can the prime minister guarantee that
none of his ministers
or advisers will contradict the rules he
set out today and if they do so
that they will be disciplined mr speaker
it's up to all of us to obey the
guidance
and uh to urge everybody in this country
to obey obey the guidance follow the
rules
because that's the way we'll defeat the
virus
thank you mr speaker the blyth valley
has recently faced tighter restrictions
as an immediate
response to a rise in local cases i know
these measures are necessary in control
on this deadly virus
but they have a real impact on families
businesses and local communities
i welcome the right honourable member
for west suffolk
decision on lifting the ban on informal
child care yesterday and mr speaker i
know
that this is a move that would be a
relief to many of my constituents
can i ask my right honourable friend the
prime minister to continue to do
all he can to support families through
this tough time
yeah i i thank my honorable friend for
the way he represents
uh blythe valiant i can't i can tell him
that we will continue to
to listen uh to people and continue to
respond
to their concerns in any way that we can
david lyndon
thank you mr speaker with 2.4 million
households in the uk facing full poverty
this
winter i figure that will only be
exacerbated by the the pandemic
will the prime minister consider
introducing a one-off code 19-1 or fuel
payment to every household
at risk speaker we will consider all
all sorts of measures to uh alleviate uh
poverty and suffering in the
months ahead the best thing we can do is
to follow this package of measures
uh scrupulously drive down the virus
keep the economy moving tim
mr speaker the last six months have been
tough for our country and it sounds like
the next six months are going to be
two and it's vital that we
it has changed our annual meeting beyond
recognition
but it has made it more important than
ever
in january i addressed the general
assembly and identified four horsemen in
our midst
for threats that endanger our common
future
first the highest global geostrategic
tensions in years
second an existential climate crisis
third deep and growing global mistrust
and force the dark side of the digital
world
but the fifth horseman was lurking in
the shadows
since january the covet-19 pandemic has
galloped across the globe
joining the four other horsemen and
adding to the fury of each
and every day the grim tall grows
families grieve
society stagger and the pillars of our
world
wobble on already shaky footings
we face simultaneously an epical health
crisis
the biggest economic calamity and job
losses since the great depression
and dangerous new threats to human
rights
you